e aí galera que assistiu campo bom com
vocês pra quem não sabe hoje é o dia das
mães quem não sabe o homem ea mulher
inglesa que sabe colocar em hajar na
sociedade ele te falar um pouquinho
liguei pra você quer assistir civil em
2030 se existir youtube hoje é o dia da
mulher se você está assistindo
lá o kameni no campo você está
assistindo esse vídeo natal hoje é o dia
da mulher o rapaz hoje é um dia em que
os caras vão começar a postar coisa
bonita no facebook para ver se consegue
uma coisa de só depois é meu amigo hoje
é o dia da aam dress code do [ __ ]
beijo na boca
o nadador 0 filho não falei que o júri
da mulher rapazes quando a mulher
tivesse sentindo código não tira onda
com ela não perguntou observador da
cólica é como se a mulher tivesse
mijando a rapadura de banda tem muitas
curiosidades sobre as mulheres não sei
se você já percebeu mas parece que a
mulher únicos e do mundo que consegue se
comunicar só com a faixa não tinha nem
falar a primeira fala assim eu já faço
eu respondi é incrível incrível por isso
que a mulher é um dos seus mais perfeito
está até outra coisa eu sei se vocês já
perceberam também mas a mulher quanto
mais nervosa ela vai ficando mais fina a
voz dela fica a céu aberto que
manchester de button na sua blusa me
explique eu quero que eu quero eu dizer
que pode sair com meus amigos só pode
fazer o que quiser eu volto com marca de
batom pra cá sem falar na tpm né até
pingüim até pm ao contrário do que os
homens pensam num dia em que a mulher
está infectada com o mundo é um dia em
que ela andou mundial de vôos e mulher e
tpm é difícil entender demais é porque a
mulher com tpm ela junta todas as
emoções ela juntos ligado porque quer
falar comigo com raiva e agora sai sai
não quero falar com você não quero falar
com você e não a sinto parte de dote sem
falar comigo sumir
em frente eu te odeio o quanto gosta de
todos sem fala comigo na obra sabe que é
um lugar mas enfim essas são as mulheres
as mulheres são as coisas mais
maravilhosas que deixou página até ela
não exige muito e você não tá vez em
quando repara na unha dela pergunta se
ela fez alguma coisa no cabelo mesmo que
tenha cortado uma unha de diferença não
é elogiado naquele vestido novo que ela
comprou fazer isso parece coisa de gay
mas não é coisa de gay é coisa de homem
pra a mulher bem é coisa de homem tão
feliz de da mulher feliz dia da mulher
você menina que está entrando em seus 18
anos já começa a aprender com a vida
feliz dia da mulher pra você dona de
casa que cuida de seus filhos a educação
dele e da mulher e você que é advogada
promotora juíza carpinteiro engenheira
tudo e sei que você conquistou
você merece e essa é minha homenagem pra
vocês muito obrigado a todo mundo o
facebook dois temas se você gostou desse
vídeo clipe gostei clique em adicionar
aos favoritos que isso ajuda muito você
não está inscrito neste canal e quer
receber mais vídeos meus clique aqui
embaixo inscrevesse assistir os outros
vídeos aqui agora essa camisa é legal
aqui ó orgulho de ser nordestino ciap
reinam no braã from piauí e tudo que o
rei todas essas camisas legais você vai
encontrar na primeira página no facebook
está aqui na descrição desse vídeo só
clicar em curtir a página e perguntava
como faz para adquirir sua camisa
curtir a página é importante e me segue
no twitter me assim no facebook curtir
minha página curtir a página piauí da
depressão e muito obrigado falou eu tô
gravando veio